[Music]
let's go out to Columbia Tennessee and
talk to Melissa what's up Melissa hey Dr
John what's up um just a lot of mess
going on uh oh tell me about
it so husband we've been together for
about seven years um got married last
year
um and about six months ago I entered an
affair with another man okay um and at
this point I am it was started out as
something fun I know that's stupid um
but it turned into something a lot more
emotional than I
expected and now at this point I just I
don't know what to do I mean I do know
what to do but I don't know what to do
at the same
time like I know cheating on my husband
is
wrong but at the same time I have really
deep feelings for this other man and I'm
in love with two men at the same time
and it's just very
difficult what's Difficult about it for
you well it's because I love my husband
you hold on hold on you don't and you
have HT him so that that ship sailed
like what's hard about
it I just don't know what to do with the
point I I mean I I my husband doesn't
know um what's going on um the other
gentleman does know that I am
married
um
and I don't want to leave my husband but
I don't want to break things off with
this other gentleman either so let me
let me put Let me give you another side
to this okay so okay number one I don't
think you love your husband I don't I
think you love the idea of the security
that seven plus years of of Quasi stable
relationship
brings I also think because well I'll
just leave it at that I also think deep
down you understand that you are with
somebody of so little
character that he doesn't mind blowing
up another
family so he can hook up a
somebody so I think you found yourself
in like a
pretty pretty uh
dicey moral dilemma and this isn't who
you want to be is it no it's not I mean
I consider my I I've never done anything
like this in my entire life hold on hold
on I don't care about that because you
are right you are right now you right
now and so that we can say those kind of
statements to make ourselves feel better
in the moment let's don't do that let's
don't try to like uh numb over this
moment okay it sucks and so I don't see
a way where all of this doesn't end in
Ash maybe it
does if you go back to your husband you
cut this off and you never talk to this
stranger again as long as you live
ever um and your husband chooses
to build something new with you because
your marriage as you know it is over
it's over completely burned to the
ground and if y'all choose to build
something else cool
or you leave your husband of of one year
plus six years and
you make a life with this dude and
you're always going to know he's the
kind of guy that really doesn't
care he'll blow up somebody's family
just to get
his it's both hands right
yeah so like you called knowing probably
what you're going to do what are you
going to do
I I'm going to tell my husband what's
going on and uh let him make the
decision no no no no no no he doesn't
get to make this call you got to be a
grown
woman you made the decision to blow up
your house you made the decision to find
true true love finally with this dude
where'd y'all meet the gym of course is
he a personal trainer he's not
okay um let me ask you this what what
was it about seven years with the guy
that became your
husband what about that
relationship it's been difficult um
we've had a lot of ups and downs I
suffer from mental illness I'm a
recovering drug addict okay so he's been
with me through a lot of stuff and I
felt like I owed my life to him for
pulling me out of everything I don't
feel like we're compatible in a lot of
ways
because I like a lot of emotional touch
a lot of affirmation and I don't feel
like I get that have you ever been
really specific and clear with him about
what you need several times and he's
good for a couple of days and then he
just kind of falls back into Old Habits
okay why did you marry him I felt like I
owed it to him honestly for everything
that he went through with
me um hospital stays rehab
that kind of thing so I just felt like I
owed it to him to stay with him because
he stayed with me through a lot of crap
that most men wouldn't have
yeah and I think relationship and love
out of obligation eventually runs out of
gas yeah and sometimes what seems like
the the kindest thing to do can end up
being the crul
thing because he's been through Helen
back with you and he saw something in
you seven years ago that you couldn't
see in yourself right right and he and
he took that trip and instead of you
having the harder conversation saying
honey I'm not going to marry you I'll
always have a place for you in my soul
like like you walked alongside me
through some darkness and
um also I don't think we were meant to
be romantically involved for the rest of
our lives to build a life together um
both of those things can be true
and that might that might sound mean but
it's just him being honest but looking
him in the eye and say I do forever and
then immediately finding somebody new to
hook up with that feels more cruel
right what is it about your home that U
makes you feel like you're slowly
suffocating I it feels very controlling
in a way I my husband sees every dime
that I spend I have no access to any of
our financial
accounts I get an allowance of what I
can spend every week and he still like I
said he sees every dime I spend so he's
your dad he's not your
husband can't go anywhere I mean yeah it
feels that way sometimes and I've told
him that you're not allowed to go
anywhere I not without telling him where
I'm
going so you're an abusive controlling
relationship
it seems that way sometimes
yes
okay here's what I want you to do
okay
um I want you to go find somebody to
talk to you today before you talk to
anybody do you have
somebody I have a I have a I mean you
have a counselor in town you need a
neutral third party I do have a
counselor um it's my pastor at church
one of my pastors okay have you told
your pastor what's going on I have not
okay man this is hard here's why this is
hard oh boy I'm gonna get myself in
trouble
here
um all right I was just going to say it
so I need you to sit down with
somebody who is not going to immediately
default to sending you back to an
abusive
relationship and there's some are there
are some
extraordinary
brilliant trained
pastors
who understand that Fidelity in a
marriage is bigger than just who had sex
with
somebody but you can have Financial
infidelity and you can have um you can
stomp somebody's soul out and you're not
being a person of Fidelity in
marriage and my fear for you is that you
go tell a pastor and by the way I'm
telling you right now this other
relationship at the gym ends in a
supernova period and people on the
internet be like you don't know you
don't know I'm telling you right now
this ends bad okay so I would put that
one to bed and anybody who tells you
otherwise like no just go try it out and
see how it goes they're just that's just
YOLO nonsense okay
but if your pastor somebody who will
listen to you and will hear you and will
hear you for the mess that your marriage
is right now and isn't instantly going
to say not to stay with knucklehead I
think you should cut that one off that's
just if you were my sister or my friend
I would say just be done with that you
what you're feeling is somebody treating
you on an equal playing field you're
feeling alive for the first time
probably post
sobriety and it feels like love it is
not it is two people that met at a gym
and they're hooking up the other side of
that is uh and by the way when you one
of you has security and one of you has
endless amounts of Freedom you can lay
together and dream and talk about the
future you can do all that stuff with no
strings attached because one of you's
anchored in and the other one's just at
CA when you end up breaking up with uh
if your husband you decide to break up
you're going to realize what a mess it
is what I'm nervous about is you go sit
with a pastor who's well-meaning and
says you have to end this relationship
at the gym fair I agree
and you've got to go back and be
subservient to a person who is abusive
to
you and that's where I would challenge
him here's the deal you may end up with
nobody at the end of this deal and I
don't know that that's the wrong move I
don't know that that's not the right
thing right
now being alone scares me honestly of
course it does probably terrifies
you does being in an abusive
relationship terrify you a little bit
Yeah is being with somebody whoat never
help me so I've never thought of it as
abusive if somebody won't let you be a
person of
agency they treat you like their
daughter that is controlling now he
would probably tell me if I was talking
to him on the phone dude you don't know
how many nights I had to go find her in
an alley and the knights in rehab the
knights in the hospital we've created a
system that works to keep her alive is
that probably what he would tell
me
okay
yeah actually I'm going to back out of
all my advice okay I'm not going to tell
you what to do here I'm going to tell
you cheating on your husband's not right
never is it okay it's not
okay all right I'm going to tell you I
think you should go talk to your pastor
or your counselor and sit down and say
Here's what's happening here's where I
am and here's the things that my husband
does that makes me feel
unsafe and I also know that even though
this other person makes me feel alive
it's a side it's not
real and that you don't know what to do
next okay
okay is that is that fair yes and do you
understand I'm not yelling at you I'm
not mad at you I know I'm my heartaches
for
you I can't even imagine the road you've
traveled
right probably not yeah I'll say this
I'm glad you're still
here if you are wrestling with mental
health challenge
Alles please get under the care of a
trained licensed professional um I'm
going to give you three months free with
my friends at better help and stay on
the line we'll get you a code and you
can connect with a licensed counselor
licensed therapist there that can walk
alongside
you your husband's going to get to
decide if he wants to stay he doesn't
get to decide what you do you you're a
grown adult you get to decide what
happens
next I'm going ask to be a person of
good character and to admit where you've
gone sideways and to admit that you've
hurt
people and to also make a decision
moving forward that is in alignment with
your values with who you want to be with
your
character there is no way forward
without pain it's going to hurt it's
going to hurt multiple people it's going
to be a
mess and I promise you there's light on
the other side of it if you be a person
of character walking through it and if
you get people to walk with you can't do
this by
yourself thank you for the call Melissa
let us know how it goes I can't wait to
hear about this
one